to the other big story in the campaign
trail this weekend and that's Charles
Koch coming out and not ruling out the
possibility but backing Hillary Clinton
let's play a bit of that interview from
the weekend as far as the growth of
government the increase in spending it
was two and a half times under Bush that
it was under Clinton so is it possible
another Clinton could be better than a
another Republican it's an awesome room
it's possible you couldn't see herself
supporting Hillary Clinton could you we
would have to believe her actions would
be quite different than a rhetoric and
that is my four-color Jonathan Karl from
ABC News so Megan I found this pretty
remarkable Charles Koch not ruling out
the possibility of backing Hillary
Clinton I mean absolutely remarkable we
have to remember that this is a man who
whose political operation had vowed much
earlier in the season to spend as much
as nine hundred million dollars backing
Republican candidates up and down the
slate and state national elections this
year look this just shows how people
like him are so baffled by the rhetoric
we've seen by some of the themes we've
seen dominate in this election whether
it's Trump's ban on Muslims entering the
country as he mentioned in that
interview whether it's immigration
whether it's the policy in the Middle
East that Ted Cruz is advocated for sort
of a hail of bombs across in an effort
to fight Isis and how destabilizing this
has been for even members of these well
you know members of not even the
establishment but the money player that
is Charles Koch it is a remarkable turn
of events that he would even say that
he's considering backing her and megan
is it any indication of the difficulty
that Donald Trump if he were the
candidate would have and unifying the
Republican Party behind him I think any
of the candidates right now perhaps with
the exception of John Kasich would have
trouble unifying both Cruz and Trump are
just on such extremes of the party and
have such extreme ideals for many of
them